1 April 1976 in Palo Alto Kalifornien
Gründen drei Männer mit 1300 US-Dollar
in einer kleinen Garage ein Unternehmen
sie haben eine Vision die so absurd
scheint dass niemand außer sie selber
daran glauben diese drei Männer heißen
Ronald Wayne Steve wasniek und Steve
Jobs und ihre kleine Idee Taufen sie
Apple das Unternehmen das heute knapp 50
Jahre später tägliche Begleiter und
Arbeitsgeräte für Millionen von Menschen
produziert und die Entwicklung des
Internets wie wir es heute kennen
maßgeblich mitgestaltet haben diese
Story und dieser Spirit sind auch heute
50 Jahre später genau das wonach
tausende Menschen auf der Welt streben
und um dieses Gefühl selber zu erleben
und euch näher bringen zu können heiße
ich euch herzlich willkommen zu meiner
neuen
[Musik]
Serie so episch und glamurös ist die
Story aber eigentlich gar nicht und um
ehrlich zu sein ist vermutlich noch nie
irgendeine Startup Story so glamurös
gewesen der Spirit von Startup
Unternehmertum Investment hat mich schon
immert okay wahrscheinlich nicht so früh
aber deswegen habe ich damals die
tradeup Serie gestartet wo ich viele
kleine Ideen ausprobiere Hülle der
löwentests wo ich mir die neuesten
Erfindungen und Projekte anschaue oder
auch ein Wohnungsumbau um ins imog Game
reinzuschauen aber ich will mehr mehr
wissen mehr lernen mehr erfahren und
euch mit auf die Reise nehmen und eine
Idee entwickeln an der ich über Wochen
Monate oder sogar Jahre arbeiten kann
und da bin ich nicht der einzige um
genau zu sein wurden nämlich 2022 2618
Startups gegründet aber was sind
Startups eigentlich im Prinzip sind es
junge Unternehmen mit einer Innovation
oder stark skalalierbaren Geschäftsidee
wodurch sich das Feld ziemlich gut von
normal Neugründung unterscheiden lässt
beutet gründest du ein Unternehmen zur
Reinigung von Fassaden wie es auf tiktok
häufig gezeigt wird du und dein Kumpel
kaufen sich einen Hochdruckreiniger ihr
geht von Tür zu Tür und reinigt Fassaden
wäre das eher eine konventionelle
Tätigkeit und würde nicht in den Sektor
Startup fallen baust du aber z.B eine
Software die sich darum kümmert Personen
mit einer dreckigen Fassade und Fassaden
Reinigungsunternehmen zusammenzubringen
wäre das vermutlich ein Starter in
Deutschland sind mittlerweile 33
Startups beim absoluten Holy Grail der
startupszene angekommen sogenannte
Unicorns was S viel bedeutet wie dass
sie mit ein ein Milliarde oder mehr
bewertet sind das heißt nicht dass auf
irgendeinem Firmenkonto eine Milliarde
rumliegt sondern viel mehr dass der Wert
der Firma eine Milliarden Euro
überschreitet und das geht
folgendermaßen Fassaden clean iO ist in
100 unternehmsteile aufgeteilt die alle
dem Gründer gehören um das Unternehmen
aber weiter aufbauen zu können sucht er
jetzt strategische Partner und findet
einen Hersteller von Reinigungsgeräten
der Interesse hat Geld zu investieren
und der kauft ze von den 100
Unternehmensanteil für einen Preis von
100 Millionen Euro ab aufgrund dieser
Information lässt sich hoch bzw
unterrechnen dass jeder einzelne
Unternehmensanteil 10 Millionen Euro
wert ist was bedeutet dass alle 100
Unternehmensanteile also das Unternehmen
an sich in seiner ganzen Fülle insgesamt
eine Milliarde Wert ist natürlich ist
das jetzt nur sehr vereinfacht gesagt
und eigentlich wird noch auf Umsatz
Gewinn Kosten und so weiter geschaut wie
man genauso einen Investor oder
strategischen Partner findet welche
Unterschiede es bei Investoren gibt und
welche Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten es für
Startups gibt besprechen wir in der
kommenden Folge anhand eines konkreten
Beispiels nämlich meine Startups also
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
um das nicht zu verp passen und ja in
meine Idee in der ihr im Laufe des
Projektes erfahrt wurde schon Geld
investiert und apropos mein Startup
genau damit legen wir jetzt los und ich
bin offensichtlich natürlich in einer
etwas Besonderen Position wie es auch
einige andere sind es ist würde ich
sagen schon fast zum Trend geworden das
Creator Startups könen und das in
verschiedene Richtungen und da gibt es
einige Unterschiede die sehr wichtig zu
machen sind und das erkläre ich euch
anhand von zwei Beispiel Riso gründet
einen Software Startup und Eli gründet
einen Software Startup Riso baut ein
Tool namens nindo übrigens ein Plus mit
Sternchen ist um die mittlerweile
riesige creatorzene im Blick zu behalten
wer macht wie viele Views wer hat wie
viel abonnentenwachstum wer hat welche
Skandale und so weiter die Informationen
sind vorrangig wichtig für
Geschäftskunden also Agenturen und
Firmen die beispielsweise Werbung buchen
Eli hingegen baut ein Tool namens
perform all das Tipps und Hilfestellung
im Fitnessbereich gibt Rezepte
Übungsanleitung und so weiter die App
ist klar auf die einzelne Person
ausgelegt die eben fit werden möchte
dieser kleine aber feine Unterschied ist
unheimlich wichtig um zu wissen in
welche Richtung man eine Idee oder ein
Tool bauen möchte und für wen es am Ende
bestimmt ist nindo richtet sich an
Businesskunden ist also B2B Business to
Business und perform all an consumer
also B2C business to consumer und all
das macht natürlich Sinn Creator Merzen
durch ihre eigene Reichweite einen der
größten Kostenpunkte von Startups
nämlich Werbung einfach aus und machen
sich dazu sollte das Startup erfolgreich
sein auch noch unabhängig von
Werbepartnern die für gewöhnlich das
ganze Creator da sein mit allen Kosten
finanzieren bedeutet volle Kontrolle
über das zu beewerbende Produkt man
verkauft keinen Scheiß sondern genau das
was man selber entwickelt und entworfen
hat und übernimmt dafür auch die volle
Verantwortung und dann kommt die Frage
was will ich machen ein Weg der häufig
gegangen wird sind consumables Chips
Pizza Getränke all die Produkte die man
eben aufbraucht und neu kauft wenn sie
denn schmecken sobald man es in den
Einzelhandel schafft hat man Werbefläche
die deutlich größer ist als die eigene
Reichweite die eigenen Produkte stehen
in Regalen an denen täglich Millionen
von Leute Vorbeigehen eben auch die die
die Videos gar nicht kennen absolutes
positiv Beispiel sind hier für mich robs
Chips guter Geschmack immer wieder neue
Sorten und vor allem aber unheimlich
gutes Design klar die eigene Community
kauft die Produkte um sie mal zu testen
aber damit es eben über die eigene
Reichweite hinausgeht muss das Produkt
erst im Regal und dann im Mund
überzeugen Menschen die eine Gewohnheit
haben bei jedem Einkauf einfach
chipfisch zu kaufen müssen von dem
Design und der Positionierung im Regal
überzeugt werden um die Gewohnheit zu
brechen das Produkt mitzunehmen und dann
zählt der Geschmack die Haptik die Tüte
die Füllmenge und so weiter aber will
ich das überhaupt ich glaube eher nicht
und das aus gutem Grund consumables
haben nämlich einige riesenprbleme
gerade wenn man das Projekt selber mit
einem kleinen Team umsetzen will oder
vielleicht sogar Ambitionen hat
irgendwas international relevantes zu
machen was definitiv cool wäre der
Lebensmitteleinzelhandel ist in allen
Ländern unterschiedlich aufgebaut und
selbst auf nationaler Ebene gibt es
verschiedene Ketten die schon
unterschiedlich gemanaged werden was es
unheimlich schwierig macht wirklich
große Marktabdeckung zu erlangen und
hierbei mal ganz davon abgesehen dass es
unheimlich TEU ist Produkte im LEH zu
verkaufen riesige Lebensmittelkonzerne
die hinter den meisten wirklich
erfolgreichen konsumobils stecken geben
Millionen für Marktforschung aus
schicken Mitarbeiter in Läden um Regale
umzusortieren so dass ihre Produkte auf
Augenhöhe sind und so weiter Menschen
überall auf der Erde haben
unterschiedliche geschmcker bedeutet
verschiedene Produkte für verschiedene
Länder deswegen schmeckt Fanta in
Deutschland eben anders als in
Frankreich oder den USA was den
Produktionsprozess unheimlich schwierig
macht dann Lagerung Transport und
natürlich unheimlich hohe Investition
und ganz ehrlich was was hat mein Kanal
mit Essen am Hut was hat mein Kanal mit
Getränken am Hut gar nichts es geht auf
meinem Kanal eben nicht um Sport was es
nahlegen würde irgendein fitnessgränk zu
produzieren oder um Essen und Kochen was
nahlegen würde irgendeine Speise zu
produzieren auf meinem Kanal geht's um
Geld Geld verdienen irgendwelche
Aktivitäten und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen oder zum Großteil Naivität und
in neue Projekte reinschnupper wir
suchen also etwas von dem jeder Einzelne
einen Mehrwert hat etwas bei dem wir uns
nicht in das heifespecken von Riesen
Lebensmittelkonzernen Wagen etwas dass
ich selber ohne Finanzspritze
finanzieren kann kan etwas das sich gut
internationalisieren lässt und einen
echten Bezug zu mir und meinem Kanal hat
denn genau das ist mein Ziel ich will
ein international relevante Startup
gründen und ja das ist ziemlich
hochgegriffen und auf keinen Fall der
erste Schritt aber wer nicht wagt der
nicht gewinnt und wenn wir schon mal bei
etwas wagen sind ziel ist es nicht
möglichst schnell möglichst reich zu
werden dafür gibt es deutlich bessere
und vor allem sicherere Wege und das
mussten auch schon eine Menge Leute vor
mir lernen denn neun von Zeh Startups
gehen in den ersten dre Jahren pleite
aber wie zur Hölle findet man so eine
Idee was könnte so gut sein dass es für
jeden einen Mehrwert bietet am besten
noch kostenlos ist und sich für so eine
Serie eignet ich habe mir über Tage
Nächte Wochen und Monate den Kopf
zerbrochen bis mir eine Idee kam für die
ich nachts um 4 Uhr aus dem Bett
aufgestanden bin um im Büro alles
aufzuschreiben zu konzeptionieren
festzustellen dass es auf keinen Fall
möglich ist dieses Projekt alleine
umzusetzen ich bräuchte Leute Partner
Menschen die mehr davon verstehen aber
wo zur Hölle finde ich die ich habe die
Idee schl endlich in die Schublade zu
all den anderen Projekten gelegt die
niemals das Licht der Welt erblicken
werden weil es mir einfach zu groß
erschien doch dann kam eine E-Mail hey
wir sind drei Jungs die etwas von
Programmierung verstehen und hätten Lust
etwas mit dir umzusetzen was dann in den
darauffolgenden 10 Monaten aus dieser
Idee geworden ist ist auch für mich
unglaublich und möchte ich euch in den
nächsten Folgen dieser Serie erzählen
also vergesst nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren und auch in den nächsten
Folgen wieder mit dabei zu
[Musik]
sein